what are they gonna do about us man
that's what I asked sometime you know I
say what are they gonna do about us
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that is uh that is Brad Levine with
better off barefoot right now right
there and what are they going to do
about us that's what I asked myself
sometimes you know there used to be a
driving force in me a lot when I was
young you know I'd ask myself what are
they gonna do about me you know I think
about that in the world you know and I
would try to inspire myself and I have
those Eminem moments you know or them
eazy-e moments when I was you know you
know bustling through the neighborhood
by my lonesome just out there all lonely
legged just moving one foot in front of
the other you know just with that swaggy
neck when you you know you kind of you
put your chin up you walk chin first you
know when you get y'all when you get
your swag you get your neck all swaggy
and then you walk chin first and you
think to yourself what are they gonna do
about me you know what's the world gonna
do about me because I'm not gonna give
up they're gonna have to do something
and they're gonna have to put me down
they're gonna have to Old Yeller your
boy they're gonna have to hit me with
that euthanasia if they're gonna stop me
because I'm not I'm not gonna stop by
myself I used to think about that when I
was when I was when I was young you know
when I had that you know that wild
swagger you know you got that [ __ ] the
world [ __ ] the world
swagger yeah man and I thought that that
used to be the thing that would drive me
you know it used to be man every other
every other vertebrae of my spine was
just you know it was like Marshall mad
look like a like a just like a little
picture of Marshall Mathers than a
vertebra it would be like l1 Marshall
Mathers LP Marshall Mathers elf I've
Marshall Mathers s1 on up my vertebrae
through that whole that whole spinal
column and that's who I you know I just
had that grrrrrr
I had that angst in me and that's what
drove me you know a lot of times when I
was young was that angst that fire you
know me asking the world you know what
the root of me I would I was asking the
world what are y'all gonna do about me
how they're gonna stop me and that used
to be some anger and some swagger that I
used to run with thank you guys for
being here today
you know I I'm happy I'm happy to be
here with you guys I just got back from
Oklahoma City or not sorry I just got
back from Oklahoma up there in the
corner of Arkansas and Oklahoma you know
it's um they got a lot of wheats up
there they got a lot of hay I mean you
see a hay bale you driving you driving
something you see you know six or seven
hay bales you know you see a couple
people ducked off behind a hay bale
maybe you know you know tugging on a
pack of Winston's you see somebody
ducked off behind a hay bale maybe you
know hugging their sister a little too
hard
or you see you know a couple siblings
back there you see you know maybe um you
see somebody you know supposed to be
work and they ducked off behind a hay
bale and they you know there are they're
test driving a couple of day dreams but
that's what you would see with these hay
bales and when you get these hay bales
going that that hay bales is a place to
hide a hay bale especially in flat flat
terrain a hay bale is just a soft little
bitty mountain that is flammable and
that horses will eat and you see you set
a hay bale anyway you know if you got an
open field you put a hay bale in that
out in the middle of it suddenly you got
something to hide behind anything can
happen behind there sorcery wizardry or
light wizardry what else you could you
know you could protect yourself from the
winds behind a hay bale you know you
could um you could grow plants that need
shade you could do it behind a hay bale
you know there's a lot of things you can
do when you got that hay bale
so sometimes you if you're driving past
on the road and you look at a hay bale
you're like what the [ __ ] dude that's
just a bunch of grass got together in a
damn gangbang but when you really get
out there and look or you know and you
see what a hay bale is you see oh this
is you know this thing provides
possibility because you don't know
what's going on on the other side of
that hay bale you don't know what's
going on on the other side of that hbz
but man I had a good weekend out there I
had a really good weekend out there and
and I'm happy to be home and I'm tired
dude I'm freaking tired dude I'm tough
but we had a good we had a good show out
there we had a good show out there we
sold it out I want to thank everybody
that came out out there and you can
somebody hit the hotline with this right
here
what's up Theo this is Brian from
Arkansas man I'm just calling I just got
done watching your show you [ __ ]
annihilated man and I stuck around a
little bit I didn't know where you were
going to be coming out I wish it would
have got to meet you man but I just
wanted to call hey thanks for the show
it's [ __ ] awesome man and left letter
that mr. Xiao know that imma be gonna be
catching him next month when he comes to
man you got a brother thank you thank
you for that message and I enjoyed it
too
I enjoyed it out there a lot of good
people came out you know a lot of good
people out there holding hands and you
know a lot of just they had one dude had
real look I can't a bunch of ant bites
on his arms but you know what I'll still
I'll let that dude hug in one time I
said damn boy you know that right you
know wrapped me up in them big bite
burritos he had these big arms he's big
long just like a dam you know I mean it
was just like being wrapped in each one
each one of his arms is probably three
feet long so he just put me in this big
it was just like six feet of just ant
ant bit and burrito just real white and
just hell ant bites like this dude had
just been you know playing playing Sims
on his arms but with hands and it was
you know they had a lot of people came
out and I will tell Brendan Schaub that
are that you guys will come see him as
well I know he's
be heading there soon for I think his
second or third visit the bee sting
daddy from the fighter and the kid but
man I'll tell you this I went to see I
went to see Joey Diaz surprised him up
there on Monday last Monday and you know
man it was great you know because Joey
Joey has this special thing if you're
not familiar with Joey Diaz and you need
to go check him out he's one of a kind
you know he's like he's from like
another it's almost like he's he's like
the emerging of a couple of different
generations because he's got this
old-school generation where it's you
know he's about honor and he's about his
word but then he's got this new school
generation where he's you know all in
the psychedelics and and and thinking
and like and experimenting and and and
then he's got that kind of the seventies
kind of trapped in him or he's all about
like free love and and just bringing
everybody into the fold he's just you
know he's he's multi-generational and
he's got that special gift and he was
shooting a special for Netflix and
Netflix is a television channel but it's
on your computer and now it's actually
back on your television now which is
pretty bizarre isn't it it's like TV
came off a TV on your computer and then
now it's like oh go go and get now you
can get the computer over the on the TV
remember where you used to get it but
now it's like they took it and reshaped
it and just and then and now it's it's
back over there and and he was taping
the Netflix special for them and it was
great man he didn't know I was coming up
and I rolled up there and you know it's
you know they got you know they have
production so you get there and they
have an audience waiting outside some
white dudes some Muppet had gotten you
know the heater had got him was in Vegas
so either the heated god I may be a
hooker it bit him you know something had
happened to him and you know and he hit
the ground the EMTs are out there but
you know a couple of the EMTs they're
probably you know cooking dope on the
side and [ __ ] cuz it's Vegas you know
what I'm saying everybody somebody's a
schoolteacher but they something a
little bit of freaking warm lip out the
back door
you know they escorting so it's anything
is possible
you know they selling a little couple
Isis at Mama's got that sweat wallet and
she's vending that thing after school
you know when she's putting people in a
detention in her crotch because that's
how to make that extra money that's
Vegas and that's you know I mean the
Vegas is it's basically just a buffet
for the dark arts you get anything you
want over there get you you go you can
go rappelling off of a crack rock if you
want and that reminds me a story of my
sister one time she and I don't think
I'm talking outside of school with me my
sister and I you know she knows I love
her and we share stories but she got too
caught up on some of that dust or
something back in the day you know she
was just uh you know what I'm saying she
was just she was all about that she was
all about that gimme a D give me a you
give me a s give me a T on that does and
uh and she had a boyfriend and that's
what happened you know because sometimes
the man will be all he'll be dust it up
you know he'll be running around and I
and and he'll have you know dusty ideas
and then the lady will fall in love with
the man and then she'll get caught you
know she'll get some of that dust in her
eyes and that's just a a byproduct of
the love that she expresses for the man
and that's what happened with my sister
and so she fell in with some man and it
was getting dusted up or something and
he took her rock climbing and look dude
I think it's crazy to be first of all
you introducing somebody to rock you
know to some type of dust or
methamphetamines and then secondarily to
then physically take them rock climbing
I mean that's I mean what is that what
would Freud say about that you know when
you introducing somebody to a couple of
grams and then you introduce into
somebody to a couple of uh you know
stalagtites of granite from grams to
granite baby you know I'm saying we
getting dusted and we uh and we going
spelunking and so that's what happened
but anyway my sister went rock climbing
and they ended up climbing up to a
what's it called when people are
they're eating but ever you can see
their their vagina pee nudist colony she
got taken up to a nudist colony and they
were having a they were grilling out
they were doing barbecue because even
the naked the naked like to eat I mean
you got to think about that boy if you
take your clothes off the first thing I
want boy I have feel embarrassed about
30 seconds after that give me a [ __ ]
McRib baby give me a oh me huh all right
hall because boy I swear dude if I don't
worry about getting some of my shirt
that's the beauty about eating naked boy
sloppy joe and now if I if I got on a
nice uh you know if I got a nice seven
hundred you know count you know or if I
got on a nice like 80 80 count
threadbare shirt or something
you know or a multifaceted you know
collared shirt shirt that has a couple
of levels you know got that business top
piece that collar yeah then I might not
enjoy a chili dog the right way or I
might stick my neck out of it and eat it
away from my body
but boy you get me naked mother hey I
want a sloppy joe you know I'm saying
dude I'll let you throw did I'll let you
throw handfuls of [ __ ] warm meeting
in my mouth from about two feet away you
know I'm saying I'll take that prime rib
from close range because uh because I
don't care about getting it on my
clothes at that point you know and
that's the crazy thing we buy these
clothes and then you know because we
want to look nice and then we have to
eat all uncomfortably to keep the
spillage off of our clothes because that
look I don't trust somebody that don't
put that don't put a little bit of
condiments on their meat
if you ain't putting [ __ ] if you
don't put condiments on your meat or
condiments on your you know vegetables
or salads if you if you eaten dry you
eaten dry a salad oh was just step daddy
a rabbit huh
do your mother live head I don't know
mr. McGregor's garden units 704
or no you need to put condiments on
anything you're having you got to juice
things up but so when you don't have
that when you're not when you're naked
you'll eat something full-throttle boy
I'll take that [ __ ] straight to my face
cuz I don't care if I Cal it'll bit of
meat on my neck you don't care if I get
a little bit of sloppy joe
you know coagulated up in my navel
because I'll just dude I'll scoop a
[ __ ] hitter dude I scooped us a small
baby hitter warm yams out of my navel
and take that [ __ ] into my jaw
cuz that's who I am baby what they gonna
do about how they gonna stop me how they
gonna stop me but my sister you know
they got up there and this was a nudist
colony and they cooking out there
grilling and she said they were grilling
fresh Franks you know hot dogs whiners
and they go out there you know they got
a fresh batch of all you know Polish
sausages and whiners and everybody's out
there eating and I'll be dang dude her
boyfriend this dude you know and he was
busted up on them boulders on them baby
boulders you know heating him up with a
lighter and taking him into his brain
you know that baby Boulder smoked just
and letting the squirrels run through
his [ __ ] cerebral and this dude's out
there and he's taking my sister to a
nudist colony weenie grill out and
honestly it sounds like a fun ass date
it sounds like something you'd pay extra
to go to at one of these raves you know
for an extra $150 you can get that
special nudist colony wristband where
we'll take you guys behind the gymnasium
they got about 50 naked people hopped up
on Molly
you know grilling up a package of uh of
them um of them Johnston brats and my
stepdad used to grill up Johnston brats
for us all the time and um and he drove
an old cop car dude and everybody in the
neighborhood thought he was a cop but he
wasn't he just got that [ __ ] at auction
and so you know he got a discount on
that car but I'll be damned if we didn't
get out frist everywhere we went people
frisked him he thought I had a wire on
saying that's my daddy
I barely know him dude he owns a car
wash and he's been making love to my
mother that's our only connection so why
are you frisking me and also why are you
a 40 why is this 40 year old man
frisking me saying he thinks I'm a narc
a narc for what [ __ ] I'm nine years old
I'm 11 player ain't narking so anyway
man but my sister yeah you know uh what
was that talking about I don't know but
yeah dude they took it you know like my
sister they got she got caught up out
there on a little bit of that you know
on a little bit of that you know that
face fire a little bit of that nest and
she ended up going saw she went up she
went rock climbing up to a nudist colony
and ended up having lunch out there with
them and and in hindsight look at least
the guy took her to do things you know
and you can say that's messed up but
also a bit does a lot of people sitting
around like they're jealous right now
that your man your woman's never took
you out there for anything special like
that never took you out there for
anything brave and did a little bit of
bravery but yeah my sister was brave
like that man one of my sisters brave
like that she likes to get out there and
be out there like that
but yeah thanks for calling and thanks
for coming out there to Oklahoma you
know they had a lot of good people came
out dude had ant bites on his arms you
know we had a couple of beautiful
multiracial multi-racial couples you
know and I like seeing that beige power
that's why I'm mad because the future
brother [ __ ] is of the future is mauve
you know the future is a little bit is
mildly copper you know the future has
got that you know it's multifaceted you
know the future is multifaceted
because they got a lot of people out
there trying to get theirs and those
people are all different colors you know
all different shades and those people
are the ones that that's the team I'm on
right there people are out there trying
to get theirs you know and you ain't got
a [ __ ] nobody in your wake you know
you don't have to run around with a with
a with a wheelbarrow of plaster of Paris
and you know when just be crippling
people in your wake and then putting
them into casts you know and patching
people up after you [ __ ] him up to
get yours you don't have to do that
you know you can make it you can make
your way you can make your way with
others and that's what I realized dude
because you know I get in some of these
places and it's you know I just you know
I notice the things that get me are
there's a lot of people out there they
don't want to try you know when it's
unfortunate if they can't try if they
you know if there's something preventing
them from making an effort if they have
fear but some people they does they
don't want to they want to stay where
they are and you can stay where you are
physically that's fine but you can't
stay where you are everywhere I don't
think it that's I don't think that
that's using the gift that we have here
this time here I don't think it is you
know if you're not trying to make a move
of even emotionally you're not trying to
stay in motion intellectually you know
you're not trying to to challenge
yourself in some type of way that's my
thing man you know I can't I can't you
know I'm just realizing I don't have the
I don't have the time I don't have the
effort just to to just mill around we
got to be moving we have to be trying to
grow you know we have to we got to
because if not well what are we doing
you know it's interesting they say that
the universe expands constantly so I
must sit here and do net huh
or I'm will get out there and I'm gonna
go spelunking until I find a dang nudist
colony that's grilling up a bag of
Johnson rats and you can see everybody's
crotch at the same time young yang I
mean if that ain't beauty I don't know
what it is but it's about I think it
that I think that in that universe thing
is just a clue for us you have to expand
you got to grow you know you got to grow
it
there's too much opportunity these days
to just completely stay stagnant and all
and sometimes it's tough look it's
easier said than done but the thing is
is just take one little step one little
move in front in front of the other you
know because even old ant arms even old
ant arms came out to the show
and God has laughter and got that
calamine lotion of love in his ears and
that's what laughter is you know and
that's what we got to do we got to stay
we got to stay healing we got to stay
moving forward you know we can do it we
can do it man but I had a great time and
I appreciate that call but I went up
there and I surprised Joey Diaz I know
I'm in and out of things here but that's
how I am and especially look I'm trying
to get settled dude I've been all over
the place last week I went to I don't
even know where and then Monday I came
and went to went over to Vegas and then
we got Oklahoma and then this coming
weekend I'll be in Calgary and that's
Canada so dude I'm Jay I'm straight up
jumping continents baby yeah I'll be in
Calgary then I'll be at Imbler brewing
in Bakersfield next weekend and that is
sold out but they added a second show
and so that's what's up what else but I
went and saw Joey Diaz and man he just
you know he's that special level of
human he's so multifaceted in and we got
to watch him tape his Netflix special
and that was cool you know because
especially after all that hard work
there's that thing where you want that
you know you never know what's gonna
make a comedian or a person or a father
or a businessman or a banker or a
delivery boy you never know what they're
you know what's the thing that's gonna
make them feel complete you never know
you never know what's gonna make them
feel you know complete what's gonna make
them feel you know with that with that
with that that little thing is out there
that's gonna make them feel like oh I do
my job well you know it might be that
you're uh you know you might be somebody
that you know
you might be somebody that that paints
and everybody's trying to get you to
paint this and paint that you know oh
won't you paint this picture of these
apples paint this bowl of fruit I'm
shocked at the level of people that
[ __ ] paint fruit I mean that's crazy
when you think about it think how many
pictures of fruit are out there and
every now and then somebody pick up some
paints and some poster board and thinks
they're gonna do it different or better
hello there's about 11 million pictures
of fruit you [ __ ]
in muppet do you are you a muppet do you
have Jim Henson's hand up your ass
because they already have 11 million
pictures of fruit and you're gonna get
out there and you're gonna do that but
man I'm different I doubt that and so
it's you know somehow it's like but you
don't know when that painter people tell
him to paint this paint that and you
don't knowwe it for him and he might
want to paint a house he might want to
spray paint his stepmother you know he
might he might want to wake old Jan it
up with a couple of with that can of uh
remember that spray paint it used to
have a marble and so you knew when
somebody about the light you up white
and ink that [ __ ] boy dude you could
spray-paint somebody's eyes shut they
had this boy in our neighborhood growing
up they called him dark Benjamin and it
wasn't a black kid it was a boy and
somebody spray-painted they'd lacquered
his [ __ ] eyes shut so bad dude he
that they were closed for about six
weeks because his day I got pissed he
did want anybody touching his son after
that and he said don't anybody touch him
and the mom was like well you know they
shut it they you know they spray-painted
his eyes shut and the dad's like I don't
give a damn what they did
don't touch him and so then freaking uh
dark Benjamin had to just chill out bruh
you know and I remember his mom even uh
he was probably eight years old as mama
put him in a damn baby stroller and took
him around for safety and then he hit a
growth spurt even one
dad was out of town just for about six
weeks he hit a growth spurt and they put
him on a little dolly like one of those
little um a hand truck one of those
little dollies you used to move a bunch
of boxes at once where he set him and he
leaned that metal thing back and it kind
of props him it's got two wheels
and do dark Benjamin his that his mom
and his aunt who was you know honestly
fully lesbian they were pushing on you
know they be pushing this wheel and dark
Benjamin around because they had his
eyes all Cult shut you know from because
they spray-painted over his eyes with
one of those hard cans of lacquer hold
on I got to turn the lights on in here
all right I'm back
anyhow was I saying so so yeah you just
never but you never know what somebody's
you know what their what's their magnum
opus what's the thing that makes them
feel okay I did it you know it might be
if you a pizza delivery boy for you it
might be okay if I get to deliver pizza
and then I get invited into a threesome
or something you know or maybe somebody
lets me you know maybe some of the
ladies gonna lay there naked and let me
look at her junk while she have a couple
slices you know it might be something
like that you never know if for the
painter person it might be okay yeah
they paint somebody's eyes shut or maybe
they paint you know they paint um a
whole street in their neighborhood they
paint it yellow with a can of house
paint so next thing you know you got
that eggshell that you got that egg
shell yellow Street out there
you just never know for them that might
be like oh the thing that's that makes
them feel complete and so for yeah for
for comedians you don't know what it is
for some comedians it's going on tour
once they get to be out on tour it's you
know that's their you know they had that
Kerouac in them and they just wanted to
be on tour and be free and you know have
that feeling of walking through the
airport with their bag in their hand and
showing up into a new place to do comedy
and you know that's their thing that
makes them feel full and to other people
it may be that they have to be on
Madison Square Gardens
you know when they got to be out there
on Madison Square Gardens doing it for
some people it may be that
you know they just need a performance
for the local garden club and they'll
feel complete it's just you don't know
what somebody's you know what somebody's
top gear is what somebody is with their
em but what makes them feel complete
what answers that question you know or
acknowledges that fire in them you know
what feeds that how they gonna stop me
what they gonna do about me you know
until we get to certain parts in our
life and that gets fed a little bit but
I could imagine I don't know but I could
imagine that Joey Diaz doing a Netflix
special that that was uh that that was
something for him you know what they and
I and for me and I could be wrong and
I'm happy to be wrong dude been wrong
most of my life but I think I felt that
a little that he was you know he just
felt like it come like it it didn't
complete him but just like that it was a
stamp of approval you know and not from
his look where everybody everybody
people know he's one of the greats
just this industry because this industry
is and it's not about who's who's good
anymore who's the best this industry is
on the something else they're doing
something else and and I don't think
it's working as effectively because now
they're coming across the tracks cuz
they want to talk to these real boys
over here and these real girls over here
and they want to talk to people who who
who actually have a real story to tell
they want to talk to people who have a
chip on their shoulder because that's
where it comes from man for me that
humor it comes out of it comes it's a
necessity you know it's just um it's a
dandruff it's a dandruff of my spirit
it's something that has to that has to
come off of me and has to come out of me
just for me to feel okay so there it is
man but that's a little bit I guess of
what's been happening this week and I
just had a great time and I just had
such a great time over there in in
Oklahoma we went over to University of
Arkansas I got to see Bill and Hillary's
old [ __ ] pad you know they had the house
were built and Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton I guess I mean had sex at least
once for Chelsea you know and uh but
dude you could tell when you're riding
out that town you could feel that old
Billy was definitely they have a lot of
hills in that area and they got a lot of
hay bales and I bet they called him
hey Bill's because you could see old
Billy Oh Billy Cleese e William clean
tongue slipping off behind a hay bale
you know what I'm saying and
establishing some real the jurisdiction
back there but it was beautiful man look
I'll tell you this beautiful school the
University of Arkansas thought it was
gonna be like this look I had my
druthers about it I had my you know I
was like oh this place is gonna be like
this or like this I mean you're talking
to a you know I went to Louisiana State
University for a while and so certainly
even were a rival but man I was I was
thoroughly impressed beautiful school a
lot of a lot of a lot of a lot of
construction going on a lot of different
gradients of land so you got you know a
hill will just pop up out of nowhere so
it just adds some different levels you
know in Hills I mean you know you got a
Hills the good thing about a hill is
something can happen behind it when
you're out there on the flat flatland
there you don't know I'm singing and I
have that much fun but you got a hill
boy even if you just got a like I said
if you even just got a hay-bale boy if
you get that little makeshift freaking
land pimple then down anything could
happen right behind that thing why but
it was nice to see man look I'll say
this Bill and Hillary had a nice little
home over there
you know they had a nice little home and
I bet if you get up in there they
probably got some dirt I bet they got
some dirty drawings I know you know
hidden under the floorboard it's a
little bit of uh you know some different
pictures of cooter and all of that
because I'll say this I remember when I
was young they had a man who and I've
told this on Joe Rogan's before they had
this dude named Nick and Nick for four
dollars would draw you a picture Oh some
you know some sweet crotch for the
weekend so on Thursday night you give
Nick your money on Friday he shows up
you know with that little hitter with
that baby sketch you know that sketch
that oh I mean this sketch will just do
it even when you saw him pull the papers
out of his pocket you get a little bit
erect you know I said that was kind of
scared because you wanted to get you a
little picture and go look at it and
this dude could draw some serious you
know it was general it was general late
you know I don't my trying to be crass
but it was general labia general
whatever you know Wasi and he would draw
it up but man if you got that little you
got one of Nick's little $4 hitters man
you'd use that thing all weekend at 13
14 years old dude I'd rent out the
bathroom at my house and just stay in
that thing all weekend just learning
about my body and so I bet I bet ah
sweet Billy Clinton had a few of those
hidden in the walls over there cuz
there's no denying that that man you
know prefers female genitalia to his own
and I think that that's okay too I think
that that's okay I think it's obviously
that he's in an arranged marriage where
he's allowed to do that sort of thing or
was allowed anyway I have to get you
know these days it's aw these guys are
getting a little bit older what else man
mmm
I will let you know that this episode is
brought to you about great block pizza
at 1811 Pico Boulevard great block has
that salad pizza and that's in Los
Angeles and they got all types of
different pizza you know they got the
Bella goat you know they got a couple of
different items man I'll read you one or
two right here they got them calzones
they got them beverages they got the
Venice
deep cheese the Frenchie they got the
hunter the buster spinach button
mushrooms onions tequila-lime marinated
chicken with mozzarella cheese on a
garlic pesto sauce gray block pizza get
that hitter
oh let's take this call hey Theo just
want to get your thoughts on something I
listen to a lot of your podcasts and
I've noticed that that you always talked
about how out in Hollywood and LA and
it's hard for somebody from the south to
kind of get accepted and get jobs and
expect and also the media kind of knocks
on people from the south but I want to
know your thoughts that here in Georgia
that they Hollywood films a ton of
movies in Georgia and they have studios
in Atlanta
Marvel's done some stuff here no Tyler
Perry's got a huge studio here and I
just wanted to hear your thoughts on
that they knocked us out so much but
they got no problems coming here and
filming all their movies no look this is
a great question this is a great comment
I appreciate you calling about this you
know when I was growing up a an escape
for me I didn't like my life when I was
growing up you know and I didn't feel
comfortable you know I grew up in an
area there was a lot of poverty and I'm
not you know I'm not looking for any
sympathy here or empathy I don't know
which one actually I don't know the
difference between them but but you know
I grew up scared you know they had a lot
of dangerous white kids around me I'll
let you know and they had a lot of
dangerous black kids around me you know
because when you're when you're in a
poor a poor area and there's and as you
know extreme poverty I don't care if
those kids are black or white a lot of
them can be some real [ __ ] and and
it was scary it was scary dude I'm not
afraid to say that [ __ ] now is an adult
man wouldn't say it wasn't cool you know
I was like staying at a Ramada so it uh
so yeah it was it was alarming man and I
used television and you know things I
would see that Hollywood created is like
oh that's you know that's my life that's
what I could have you know I love
storytelling I loved all of that and so
you know eventually
you know I ended up in Hollywood and I
ended up out here and I ended up
thinking oh well this is a place I can
come to all this time I could go there
and you know you know it always seems
like this place where you can go there
and make your dreams come become a
reality and you know everybody's welcome
and this and that and then I get there
and you know it's been tough I mean
there's no southern accent you cannot
find a southern accent on television I
don't feel like I mean especially on
network TV name one name one actor with
a southern accent on network television
in the past 20 years I can't even name
one and I'm and I'm totally happy to be
wrong there may be one or two
I mean Blake Shelton you know he's not
an actor but it's like Reba you had Reba
which is one of the best shows ever but
it's just you know it doesn't feel super
welcomed and then you have a lot of you
know a lot of celebrities make fun of
people from other areas of the country
that don't live in LA or don't live in
New York or don't have a lot of money
you know they make fun of people like
where I'm from you know and that's and
it just I don't know it has left a sour
taste in my mouth you know but it
doesn't mean I'm gonna stop you know
trying to achieve some of my dreams or
cheese so my goals but at the same time
you're right brother that Hollywood at
the same time because you know
California lets so many you know they're
so open everyone and so open to this or
that or whatever that they're that they
don't get the tax breaks it's too
expensive to shoot here anymore because
the states you know the budgets so bad I
mean they're probably who knows what
they spend all the money doing I don't
know probably cleaning up all the [ __ ]
in San Francisco off of the street dude
have you been to San Francisco well I
don't even recommend it it's so just
people just judgment and [ __ ] on the
street but I'll say this man but then so
then they'll go to our southern cities
and get the tax breaks happily oh
they'll happily come over to Atlanta and
get those tax breaks they'll happily go
shoot in Wilmington New Orleans you know
it's like they just use you
that's the thing it just so I don't know
I guess I just feel a little bit I don't
know I don't feel taken advantage of but
I feel like once you get to Hollywood
anew see what's really going on you see
sometimes the hypocrisy of it and it's a
little bit sad you know and I don't like
sometimes how that it's the same way how
the news always makes fun of you know
the south they always say these people
are so racist these people are this or
that but you know but and I've said this
before but a lot of black people had to
beg to be on the Academy Awards two
years ago there's there's tons of Latino
people in America who aren't included in
[ __ ] but they don't even raise a big of
a deal about it
because they're usually just having a
great time but man it's just like I
don't know I just wish you know we would
just look at it the way it really is
that none of us are perfect and we've a
lot of shit's messed up and that this is
a dirty business out here you know so
it's just a matter of how I conduct my
own business that's all I try and worry
about but it is man I think it is messed
up you know a lot of these a lot of a
lot of Hollywood you know elites will
make fun of the plate of places that
were where we are from but then they'll
come there and get those tax breaks
won't they and that's one thing I've
realized man that money isn't loyal and
so I'm just gonna keep doing me and I'm
gonna keep doing my thing you know
and you know and sometimes I realize I
got to take back a little bit of that
childhood
ank's that I had you know I got to keep
a little bit of that edge what are they
gonna do about me because be honest I
don't think they expected a kid like me
to get out here I really don't I don't
think they
to kid off a Maggie Street to get out
here and be on the top stages coming in
after you know some of these big cats
and these big dogs and perform you know
before and after some of the greats I
don't think they expected it you know
and I'm not saying that I'm anything
special but I'm saying that I'm here you
know and I know a lot of great people in
this town and I know a lot of great
people that work hard and want to do
good stuff but I don't like that thing
where they look at me or they hear that
you know my southern accent I mean you
want to talk about people not being
welcomed if there's one group on
television or two you know I'd say it
seems to me Vietnamese people and
southern anyone with a southern accent I
mean you don't you don't see a lot of
them on television so just seems seem
pretty much you know like if it is this
for everybody
nah is it no but it's just crazy to get
all the way this far and then to look
around and be like damn I'm not am I
even allowed here
[ __ ] for everybody so but you got to
make your own way you got to make your
whole you got to make your fold you know
and I think some of the ways you do it
you know in that and that's one thing I
got to keep that I can't you know you
can have a chip on your shoulder but you
can't really because it you you know you
have to want you have to want the best
for a buddy and you can't work always
the best from a place of anger and
that's one thing I've learned over the
time is that I think I used to be a
little too angry so now most of the time
I try and look more at the positive you
know I try to think more about the
possibility you know we're not that and
I don't try to think as much they don't
want me I try to think that this is me
it's gonna be a little bit harder for me
but thankfully you know the life that my
higher power has put me through is it's
been a little tricky here and there you
know and I think that's one thing that
I'm grateful for because
and I can relate to other people who
their life has been tricky you know and
even if it's been different tricky you
know talking to a buddy of mine the
other day through a a a black friend of
mine and that's all I'll say you know
because you're not supposed to share a
lot about him but while he's talking man
I'm looking in his eyes dude and I could
feel like just disconnect like just like
a crazy connection man and I'm not
saying nobody was trying to get they
nuts out or anything like that or put
softener on each other's bodies or
anything like that you know or sometimes
they used to have these two gay men bus
would and we catch them sometimes they'd
be doing a little bit of dust or burning
and you know a couple packets of glass
and a little pipe outside and they would
get some of that downy freshener and
you'd see him out there in the backyard
at night they'd put a couple towels on
the ground and put downy freshener on
each other's bodies boy and look I only
reason out watch this because that [ __ ]
smelled good man when you were a kid
dude if you grew up money bro you didn't
have parents dude you had the smell of
downy freshener I mean now if I smelled
that downy fresh sure man it made me
feel like everything was okay
you know I get that hit of downy
freshener and I felt like everything was
okay I mean I remember you know my
father wasn't you know and I I get
sometimes a little bit in the end of
this kind of stuff and I don't want
anything to be you know talk about
family stuff sometimes another if I
could talk about some of this emo stuff
too much but you know my father one of
the best memories that I have or one you
know thinking about smells and how they
take care of us at times you know and
we'd see those man-bra double Ricky bro
cuz both these dudes were named Ricky
these gay men and they were lovers I
think or something you know and they
were both real real lean because they
were out they they you know these were
rest area leave a couple of rest area
bad boys you'd see him out there by the
interstate being bad boys you know and
they were smoking glass and one of them
worked up actually at a um you know one
of them just wrote a bicycle all the
time I don't know if that was a job but
he did it and and the other one worked
at Auto Body you know beating rust off
of um catalytic converter
[ __ ] like that making recyclables you
know trying to get things enough rust
off of them for them to be considered
recyclable so I don't know if that's
also a job either but anyhow you know we
would um oh but another smell I remember
might you know I mean I've said this
before the hardest-working man I've ever
known was my mom and and she had she had
this cow skin this cow skin rug in her
room
and this before animal right since when
animals didn't care that a lot of
animals believe that they were here to
sacrifice their lives so the rest of us
could eat and stay warm and stuff like
that and a lot of animals still do there
are some animals that don't think that
and they you know were raised in hell
but there are some that um that are
still ok with that because you know
animals believe in reincarnation do you
know that yeah that's the only thing
it's pretty cool about animals they
believe it that when they die they come
right back as another animal and even a
cuter animal so I mean if I were you
know if I were a armadillo I'd straight
up I'd take my own life boy you know I
come back as a damn juice beautiful
little la koala but but my mom had this
cow skin rug in a room or and I remember
sometimes I lay in there and my mom
would uh you know mom worked so much the
only time I get to spend a lot of time
with there was at night I would watch
her get ready brush her teeth and floss
her teeth and you know she you know have
her nightgown on and she put on you know
lotion and just be like a lady you know
do lady type of stuff nothing wild or
anything perverted you know and but I
would lay there on that rug and I put my
Bob my face up next to that cow skin
next to that hide and I didn't hail that
smell and there was just that that
leather smell you know that's that manly
that leather you know just that you know
the embodiment of cleanse you know like
a Clint Eastwood or the Ponderosa or you
know Montana anything that seemed manly
or virile
they came into my census through that
hide and it almost it filled my brain
almost with like a father-figure type of
smell and I remember at those moments
where were some of the moments that I
felt most like familial if that makes
any sense most okay you know most part
of you know like I had two moons you
know like I had you know like paint like
it was this the most time where I felt
like both my parents were very present
and that was when you know in the
evenings when I would see my mother you
know in a very womanly way you know you
know she'd have put her hair up or you
know and you know when they would put
pout you know nothing perverted but just
you know she'd be in her night robe and
you know you'd smell like you know
lotion arm lotion and all of that and
and uh and then I'd have that same smell
of the of the hide from the cow and it
would make me feel parented if that
means anything and I know that's bizarre
but you know you just don't know where a
smell is going to come in to you and how
that's going to resonate inside of you
and make you feel but but yes you know
but I got to live these days out here
and not not come from a place of anger
because I don't want to come from that
place anyway but every now and then dude
I would be lying if I say that I didn't
feel unwelcome here sometimes but I'm
not going to give up and because you
know why because I don't want there to
be here's what I don't think I don't
think that you teach anybody anything by
making them feel unwelcome you know I
don't think you meant I remember
especially whenever the election was
going on his stuff dude I mean people
looked at me like I was you know like I
uh like I was like a you know just
people that had never even been to the
towns I'm from are the places I've lived
are the places you might have lived
people that have never even been there
look you just say acting like people
that are from these places are [ __ ]
or aren't as good as them or worth you
know being around them because they
might have some different thoughts or
different beliefs or they might just
live in a different world you know it's
uh it you know it and I don't want that
that's what I don't want I want there to
be because that doesn't help anybody
because now if there's a kid sitting at
home where I was sitting and he's
watching and he's listening you know one
of his favorite celebrities and they're
telling him that the people from his
town or his parents just cuz they voted
a certain way or they behave a certain
way or not behave but because I don't
mean behavior but because they're from
an area where what you know that is more
conservative or has more I don't know
[ __ ] owns an animal that lives
outdoors what about that has a dog that
sleeps on the porch that's suddenly that
they're bad people
because that doesn't help that kid you
know that doesn't help the next me
that's somewhere that doesn't help him
it doesn't help them in fact it just
makes him angry it just makes him angry
and if he's already has a lot of like
questions his mind then it don't not
only does it make him angry at the
celebrity that he cared about but then
it also makes him angry it could even
make him angry at his parents and so
then where does he have you know cuz the
or what if you used Hollywood as an
escape you know some of these shows and
now his favorites his favorite
celebrities are judging him it just it
doesn't do anything there's no solution
there there's no solution I don't think
anyway and I'm okay to be wrong with
that
so you know I want a kid if they see me
or they hear me talking about it they're
like oh this kid can do it you know this
kid sounds a little bit like me you know
because look I get it
people people live in different Americas
dude they are different you know and I
even go it's like you know people talk
about my moment when they have the
statues in Louisiana and they were
taking the statues down in New Orleans
and I can totally see it I see it you
know like if there's a statue and it
represents a
you know if the general was a slave
owned or something like that and it you
know and half the city's population is
black and that makes I get that I
understand it it doesn't make a ton of
sense but that's also I remember growing
up in that area and we would go meet at
this at the robert e lee statue and
everybody would meet up and have fun
together black or white and it was at
the statue nobody there gave a [ __ ] so
then it's just this outside judgment
comes in and looks sometimes you know
and then maybe sometimes it's an
evolution of time and you know different
another generation starts to have a
different perspective and that's fine I
get it you know and since the statues
have been taken down I don't think most
people give a dang but I just don't like
some of that judgement when people who
don't live somewhere start saying oh
this isn't how it needs to be over there
you know just because those people live
by the water as Bill burr says just cuz
you think just because you live by the
water you think you you know it all it's
just not fair it's not cuz you don't you
don't know what it's like there you
don't live there you live where you live
and if just you you're bored cuz your
life so comfortable lucky you you know
and I live here now so it's I mean it's
been interesting man I didn't mean to go
so deep on this but you know things
happen man let's take a call right here
on the hotline dude I got some this we
have the best calls ever I believe have
come in on this episode I'm so grateful
for anybody that has hit the hotline you
can always hit the hotline if you have
any thoughts or suggestions or
commentary on anything that's being
discussed on this podcast don't feel
like you don't have a voice the number
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three this episode is brought
to you by Specter Specter is a binary
options trading platform that takes the
middle man out of trading no more
middleman no more sheisty guy showing up
in a camel hair suit you know with a
stack of
money on a stick on his back no more of
that okay it's all crypto based so all
transactions happen on the blockchain
straight off the blockchain meaning
there is no broker that could
potentially rip you off our chain or
charge excessive fees no more brokers
try the demo today at the link below and
in the episode notes
it comes with $60,000 in crypto currency
for you to play with you want to trade
US dollars for Japanese yen get out
there you are you just gotta click the
spektr link you wanna you want to trade
British pounds for euros click the
spektr link you want to trade dollars
for Kryptos or just learn more about
crypto currencies and trading in general
click the spektr link try the demo with
the spektr link below and in the episode
notes and within minutes you will feel
like a Wall Street trader with all the
tools that the big dogs use once you get
the hang of it sign up for a verified
account and start making real trades
with real money
sorry America real trades are for
outside of the United States only but
you can practice as much as you want
still try the demo play with the
simulated 60,000 and see if you have
what it takes at the spektr link below
and in the episode notes alright let's
get into a call right now here we go
with that video this is kale be out here
Kentucky man in southern Kentucky Wow
Kelby in southern Kentucky I didn't know
there was a southern Kentucky really
that's a double entendre thank you for
calling Kelby on word and I just had a
question on what you might be thinking I
am 23 years old and I have you know
developed a little bit of baldness on
the top okay boy you got that baby's ass
on the top huh that's beautiful dude
dude in some countries that's a sign of
um you know hope I think in Japan that's
a sign of hope if you have any hair on
your head people you know people think
oh man I hope I hope he's ok with that
maybe homework and I decided to shave my
head about a year ago and I've been
doing ever
yes then people who weren't know me have
asked me questions such as am i racist
now that's I don't mean a Lavra that is
hilarious yeah look this is bro this
goes perfectly and we're talking about
just because you have a southern accent
now and because you want to have a
haircut suddenly you're racist you know
that's like people just because they see
my haircut they ask am i uh lesbian
totally messed up let's hear more or may
jumps that I'm a scared here and I think
you know maybe they're involved a little
bit in the north part because who's to
be judging me
after I just changed my appearance a
little it's so true man it's so true you
know just because you got a how many
options you got you bout hit it
you bout hit it how many options you got
uh Kirby sorry it's not Kirby what is it
damn I don't want to go back and check
let me think
carob nope it's uh I'm sorry I'm not
trying to put your name here but I saw
sometimes I like to guess things instead
of you know just check what they are
right do this is curb care um Berkey
it's not Berkey Berkey no uh but yeah
dude so I can't guess it
but yeah it's [ __ ] up right just
because you have a certain style of cut
now suddenly you know you're a white
supremacist or you know you're gonna
start a gang in prison just because you
can't [ __ ] grow any hair just because
God don't want you to have hair doesn't
mean he then wants you to be part of
some vile group let's hear more and you
know my accent doesn't help and I know
that but I just wanted your opinion on
young guys maybe have to make a big
change in their appearance that wasn't
their choice but just something that all
old Mother Nature had planned for and
look man I'll say this I think I think
it's probably a I bet at a certain point
it's relaxing to have that
to have no hair you know cuz it's in a
way it's kind of it's almost just like
letting your hair grow and just go
anyway it's like the opposite of that
but it's the same thing you know you
don't have to worry about it did I used
to worry so much
brother Kirby I'm gonna call your
brother Kirby now because I don't you
know I don't want to go back and listen
because I don't want to a Huggle listen
alright what is it
what's up video this is kale be out here
in Kentucky man and step Kelby Thank You
Kelby I'm sorry
yeah Kelby it's uh you know it's not
it's it's messed up you know that's just
how you're gonna be but I bet it is
relaxing because I noticed when I could
start I used to have a regular haircut
man clean-cut and I was always trying
always felt like had to look a certain
way and my you know and I was thinking I
wish you know I mean I wish my neck was
longer and I still wish but that my neck
was I'll just so you know just a little
bit longer not much and I've actually
even kind of figured out I think almost
pretty much just wish about 3/8 of an
inch but but you know I had all these
little things and it was just so
stressful you know and always I'm always
you know I got a big nose and I got big
ears and I got you know my eyes look
like I don't know a lot if you look if
you look at my eyes you know it's just I
got all these things that made me feel
inferior you know when I just and I was
always just standing in a way to come oh
let me the stand up straight and just
put your chin out a little see you have
a little more turn and um don't don't
look at anything like in the center of
your face because you'll look cross-eyed
just all these things just so I could
try and appear normal and then one day
man that all got lifted off of me and I
just said I don't give it and I just let
this [ __ ] roll out of my head I just let
my hair grow out man and I just made
sure that I was brushing my teeth and
that's when I started feeling okay
but yes sometimes we have to change our
appearance you know and sometimes you
know God changes our parents or the
world around us changes our appearance
or you know or our life just changes our
appearance and we got to adapt and you
know you might lose a leg and suddenly
you got to tie off a lot of your pants
you know or you got to you know go to
that pants you know that website that's
just one side of pants but then you can
get pants you know you can cut or you
could cut your original pants and new um
you know you can aw you can cut them and
a half and just kind of have you know
and have two pairs of pants out of one
pair of pants almost you can't really
though because you don't have a top part
but but you know it's like when you got
to make those adjustments man you got to
do it and in the end it's about you
feeling okay with it you know when
you're but when you when you go bald
when you go that full natural there's a
lot of fun things you can do you could
do a scented lotion you could do a mural
you can do some art you can do a tattoo
and then you know over the parts where
the hairs gonna grow back so then you
got that tattoo but you also you know
your you know your hair is gonna grow
back over some of it so you could do
something fancy like that you can do
Christmas earrings you can do some you
know if you have your ears pierced you
can do a beautiful Christmas earrings
and do that and be that party boy with
them bells off as lobes so there's
different options there's different
specialty there's different specialty
options that you can do and I hope you
find some some peace around there let's
hear a little bit more your call here oh
but yeah if if you give me any insight
on that I'd appreciate it man I really
appreciate your podcast I recently found
a niche it did a lot of good for me and
trying to understand some of these
things I've been thinking about and you
know what you're saying right there man
that I love to hear is thinking about
because that's what we got to be doing
Kelby we have to be thinking about stuff
you know one thing I will notice as much
as there's so much like judgment about
places that aren't you know I notice
there's a lot of judgment man I noticed
in San Francisco last week
dude San Francisco that places
do four maneuver photos much judgment in
my life walking around there la has this
kind of like you're not you're too rich
people are too rich they make you feel
less than but this other thing was
happening in San Francisco where and
felt and not everywhere in the bay I'm
not saying that I was out in Alameda and
people seem down
you know people seemed a little bit more
normal I'm saying in San Francisco you
know you had first of all it's so
expensive there that even if you [ __ ] if
you get locked out of your house for an
hour you might not be able to afford to
get back in if you lock if you lose your
keys so there's an element of that going
on where it's definitely you know it's
way too expensive so they you know for
as welcoming as it is you you're only
welcome if you got money look you don't
have money you ain't welcome you know
what I'm saying
that's like I was in how I was in aa
Hawaii two weeks ago for seven weeks ago
and they had a TARDIS there and they had
an endangered TARDIS and I went right up
to it you know some ladies like back up
back up she said if you touch it it's a
five thousand dollar fine if you touch
that TARDIS and I'm like damn
so only rich people can touch it that's
all that is you know and I don't mean
that in a I'm just so that's the facts
you know people price themselves out so
much so then you have a bunch of people
having to spend all this money to live
somewhere and they just seemed angry
it just seemed angry I never felt as
much kind of anger in the air but but
just as much as they look at places that
don't want to seem progressive like
places where I'm from there's a thing
that I don't like about places some of
the place where I'm from is people that
don't want to be progressive in their
thoughts we have to continue to think we
have to continue to think about
different ways and not just get set
where we are and do I have an answer on
how to do that I may I don't
I don't really but a lot of times if we
can't think for ourselves or we can't
find a different way sometimes just
listening to somebody else that's
different from us you know that can help
us a little bit we might not agree with
it but we might get we if we get a
little piece of something from them you
know but that's what I liked about this
call Kilby's you're thinking you know
you're not just sitting there thinking
[ __ ] you know I'm a bald-headed Wildcat
imide you go join you know some type of
dam you know / you know I'm gonna go to
prison now some people they lose all
their hair they're like [ __ ] I need to
go to prison now and join a cult or
something or be a man's lover just
because so it fits with my bald head you
know where I need to be um you know who
what other is job as somebody that's
often kind of bald oh there's always
that bald guy that works on the airlines
he's a male flight attendant some bald
men will be like so you know I lost all
my hair now I need to you know suddenly
start dating men and work for an airline
but you're not doing that you're just
saying hey I lost all my hair and now
let me think let me think about when I
you know I don't like that people judge
me just because I have a southern accent
man it's the same type of [ __ ] where
they had so many people saying don't
judge don't judge but then the second
you see they take the low-hanging fruit
like it's easy to be poor and white man
said it makes me upset sometimes but but
that's okay you know that's part of our
journey man that's part of our journey
is uh and we all have it and that's
where I try to relate with people on is
on their journey man you know but let's
so let's get another call right here
here we go hey Theo I had a self-esteem
question for you man
so okay thanks for calling oh and in
middle school I gained a whole bunch of
weight I was a heavy boy
I'm criminal South as well the one when
I gained Wow a lot of southerners today
thank you for calling you get you gained
some weight in middle school let's go a
lot of weight I develop breasts oh boy
dude I'll tell you this store are you
making me think about this right now and
I'm not I'm not trying to interrupt you
but I'm going I'm gonna interrupt you
for a second man they had this big boy
when I was growing up and dude he got
them first he got them tots first you
know and had one girl in our school that
had him but she was uh you know she her
family was you know heavily with the
Lord and they're deadlocked you know
they kept thing all the kids locked up
in the yard and about a year and a half
later I felt in a feeling her breath
through the book through a barbed-wire
fence you know catching that Tet you
know catching that Tet a with my poem
just palming down their frickin young I
don't know if it was at it yet but it
was gonna be at it you know it was on a
girl so and that still counts and she
let me touch that warm lump and we were
both children so that's totally legal
but I remember I used to go sleep at my
buddy's house because he got tits kind
of first you know and he was a bigger
boy but man I'd sleep over there dude a
month dude I swear man my penis would
get so hard bro not at him but at the
tits and I would even put my hands like
this it's because I saw I wouldn't see
the rest of his body I would just see
the breasts
you know because I wasn't thinking about
men I was just thinking about tits you
know and so I would just see it you know
I would just make a little kind of
squint area like I see them big
beautiful you know them just flashbulbs
of straight up you know them straight up
leche duffels
you know them beautiful bags and that's
and I would love that man and that's a
man I was just getting so keyed up and
fired up and I remember I get so erect
sometimes as a child I'd pass out I'd be
unconscious cuz I would get you know cuz
I'm thinking that you know I got that
I'm that I got that strong you know I
got I got it's not really a baby arm I
got it's like two baby's arms and his
legs and he's standing straight up with
his arms and legs like that you know
just in a straight line I got that I got
that capacity I got that [ __ ] pasady and
so when that thing takes on the blood
when it does an all-call for that blood
and that hemoglobin do when everything
rushes into Daddy's you know into that
big into that ballast tank the rest of
me kind of sometimes will just faint I
used to get erect
faint a lot as a child but I remember
first breasts I ever saw on a beautiful
thick boy in my neighborhood and a
friend of mine he was and and I'll say
this man that there's nothing wrong with
that let's hear more van kitty
they've been there ever since no man
kitty okay got the man been there ever
since I'm 27 now I've lost a lot of
weight even in the past in the past year
I've lost 40 pounds Wow congratulations
man I can't even imagine that I can't
even imagine the the stick-to-itiveness
it's taken to do that so I hope you feel
a lot of pride in yourself man I hope
that you know people say to me a lot too
you should take a moment and think of
you know where you were before in
certain aspects your life can even be a
couple weeks ago with an attitude and
where you are now
but I hope you recognize that man that's
a huge thing to lose 40 pounds and you
must feel a lot of pride let's hear more
so the thing what was tough man is uh
the self-esteem is low man you take you
know I'm going to the beach next weekend
with my family and the idea of taking my
shirt off and being around the beach is
terrible you know I've been to the beach
before man and I try to like make light
of the situation you know I've kind of
like told jokes about like how uh how
it's okay for me to take my shirt off
because I'm a male even though I have
titties bigger than you know half the
females on the beach I mean yeah man I'm
kind of feeling a little bit sorry that
was me you know I wasn't making fun
earlier but I was telling you a story
that kind of I guess correlated this
maybe some of these those things might
have you know kind of I don't know if
hope I hope that didn't bum you out at
all because I really enjoyed seeing that
on my friend but you know I can imagine
what it was like for him and now I'm
kind of learning that perspective let's
hear some more just trying to figure out
man like how can I like embrace it you
know and surgery is an option but it's
about you know yeah that surgery I know
it's about five to 7,500 and then you
also have to wear special shirts and
stuff at agreein and then you have to
take about two weeks off of work
all right man I you know I appreciate
that call man it's brave to call about
that you know I mean if you're nervous
you know I'll save you a couple things
one if you're nervous about the surgery
you know obviously I'm sure you've
probably researched and talk to people
and you can find other people that have
had it I have a friend actually a
comedian friend who was just telling me
the other day that he had this same
issue and then he ended up having the
surgery and that finally after years a
lot of that inferiority and I don't know
if that shame but you know just that
nervousness has gone away from him
because obviously he's you know his body
looks different now but that that ran
real heavily with him for a while yeah
man that's tough because you want to
just have your shirt off and just be at
the beach and feel free you know you
want to maybe even get fully naked and
have a damn you know you know uh a
turkey burger or a um little baby Julius
Berger what is that thing called a
sloppy joe not baby Julius what am I
thinking of whoo and so you want to have
you almost want to get fully naked and
have a sloppy joe I'm trying to think of
I wish there was a special shirt that
was for a dope-ass man that had some
kind of little bit of light you know
kind of thicker and that you know then
breasticles you know I wish they had a
man like you know that could kind of you
know like a man's ear you know just kind
of something you know even if Under
Armour made one or something you know so
I don't know I mean I guess it's tough
too because I know that probably is
tough for you yeah I mean I I for me
personally what what would I do I would
probably wear some type of under armour
type of thing where I could still be
athletic a little bit and get some Sun
but I would still be able to take care
of that part of me where I didn't you
you know if it's gonna make you so
self-conscious that you're not going to
be able to enjoy yourself at all then
maybe for now I would still you know
maybe wear a shirt because because
here's the thing you're going to the
beach you want to have fun you don't
want to not be able to enjoy yourself
so you know for now I would do what it's
you know what's gonna make you feel okay
and bring you the most joy now say you
go full throttle you know when you got
them made coupes out there you know you
got them you know them lowercase a is
out there then I think have some fun you
know have some fun I mean accept the
fact that you're probably gonna get some
looks know that in advance and then
maybe have some fun with it now here's a
fun thing you could do you could get one
of those Tahitian type of things with
the coconut bra things you know like
Fred Flintstone wears because that's
something that's fun and it's all would
still kind of you know cover up some of
your nervousness so maybe that's
something fun that you could do you know
but um you know if it continues to
bother you I don't think there's any
shame and getting a surgical procedure
if you can afford it I don't know how
that works with with with insurance or
anything like that but you know what man
let me I want to know how that beach
goes and even if it doesn't go well I
want to know that if you wouldn't mind
you know I'd love to circle back with
you and find out just kind of the truth
if you can take me through some more of
that you know because I know that that
kind of stuff is tough man when we feel
our bodies are a certain way man I've
always hated like the slope of my
shoulders dude I've had a dude ever
since I was young it's a little better a
little different now but I had a real D
s booty I had the same but buttocks and
hips had a lot of down syndrome
men and women had and a lot of black
girls we had the same butt and so I'd
always get all these wild jokes and you
know I'd feel nervous everybody wanted
me to twerk all the time and [ __ ] and
I'm like [ __ ] you know so I feel you man
it's tough it's tough when we live in
this world that puts so much on how we
look and and we're so self-aware too and
then we have this you know something
that really stands out I mean dude I
wish I could wear a brassiere over my
nose sometimes you know I got a you know
I got a my nose it's kind of a c-cup so
I got that C Cup whiffer but thanks for
calling man and for just for not
thinking and not feeling that stuff
alone if you go out to the beach hope
you have a foot Obie have a blast no
matter how you no matter how
you play it I hope you have a blast man
all right let's get into another call
here
hey this is Stevie for us in West
Virginia I had a question for you what
is the biggest misconception that you've
come across being from the south
personally I was at a Six Flags and
somebody was actually surprised to see
that I owned a pair of shoes so I was
wondering like what kind of weird
stereotypes or misconceptions you've
come across certain years that's a good
one yeah that somebody thought you
didn't have shoes and that's wild
the biggest misconception me that I've
had from the south I think is just that
people think that you are just going to
be racist you know because there's
definitely a lot more race there's a lot
more racial environment growing up in
the south and and I find it's that there
was a lot of just I don't I found it was
more hatred when I was young just going
both ways you know there was a lot of
and it was a it was you know there was a
lot of black kids that were extremely
mean to white kids and there was a lot
of her people and vice versa
you know and I don't know when it
started you know I mean I mean I know
historically when things started between
those two races but I think it was
probably you know it's probably just the
assumption that everybody is gonna be
racist you know or that like people will
come up to me and refer to me as redneck
kind of stuff sometimes and that makes
me mad
it makes me a little bit upset I don't
mind being rural the other day a girl
referred to me as white trash and uh and
that kind of made me mad you know I've
kind of to me like I you know I've never
dealt with the you know the n-word
situation but it felt like that's kind
of you know so I don't know what that
feels like but it felt like kind of a
dagger like that to me you know like
them saying something that put me in a
place that I couldn't escape from as far
as they were concerned so that it made
them feel like they were better than me
and that that [ __ ] made me mad because
I'll and I also say this though that
yeah growing up in the south to youth
there's a lot more racial [ __ ] you grew
up around dude there's a lot more people
saying all kinds of stuff everybody
doing it and even out in LA you hear
local okie people saying racist stuff
all the time on both sides of the tracks
both sides of the net both sides of the
ROYGBIV of that uh of the color palette
but that's one probably that I'm
ignorant you know I felt for years as
sad as it is that I had to hide the fact
that I wasn't ignorant you know I tried
to pretend like I was you can even you
know I had to use satire because I was
afraid even sharing in my real feelings
sometimes so a lot of times I have to
disguise or hide my thoughts and my
ideas sometimes through satire because
I'm afraid that they're not gonna be
accepted you know that I'm not gonna be
heard you know I don't know man I'm
still learning a lot about this but
that's that's a wild question I
appreciate you calling in young lady
let's take another call here here we go
Sophie Amanda's done in North Carolina
that's why I tell you that I really
enjoyed that at the service all right
thanks Adam appreciate that yes Stevie
starlight was wild he came in he was 45
minutes late I'll say that I didn't say
that but he came in and he want to go
have a cigarette break like break from
what bruh you just got here 45 minutes
late daddy oh let's go you know I'm
paying I'm paying a crew what you think
daddy you know I know you've been out of
norbit's TV star light but look we need
you here in the galaxy but we had a
great time and you know he had this I
mean that it's never too late to come
over that's a beautiful song and Saul
was so grateful that he came in and and
we have fun man his girlfriend came and
sat in here on the couch and it was neat
to just talk to somebody who come out
here to you know who come to Los Angeles
with a dream and to hear with what they
thought and what what he thought all
right let's take another let's take
another call
all right here let's finish I call up
you have a phenomenal job and he's a
great guest man I really love to have
him back he can and also reported seeing
you in Raleigh North Carolina matter got
my tickets and everything
can't wait did bro be good gang gang man
yeah I'll see you uh I'll definitely see
you in Raleigh and I'll see everyone
this weekend June 15th and 16th in
Calgary Alberta Canada Yuk Yuk's then
I'll be in Bakersfield California the
following weekend then the following
weekend I'll be in Stark County Illinois
a fundraiser in my mother's hometown at
the Paramount Theatre then July 6th
through 8th the following weekend I'll
be at levity live in Oxnard California
and then July 20th through 22nd charlie
good nights in Raleigh North Carolina
some new dates added on Toronto Just for
Laughs festival and that is September
20th through the 24th go get the pass
you got to go on to the just Just for
Laughs website go get the pass and pick
the shows that I am on so you can come
and see me perform I promise I'm gonna
do my best while I'm there I promise you
I'm gonna do my best
also we have Washington DC has been
added that's November 30th through
December 1st at the comedy loft November
9th and 10th Salt Lake City we're gonna
get over there I'm really excited and
we're gonna do some some some magic
there at wise guys in Salt Lake City
other dates there's some other cities go
to Theo van comm slash tour tio you are
what else man we'll go to a couple more
calls here man and then we'll probably
you know we might try to get through
this but we have so many great calls
let's go hey wassup Co this is Jay from
Texas man :
what's up Jay thank you for calling
brother then going to get some things
I'm actually uh this past weekend you
know my dad passed away oh man I'm sorry
to hear that man you know I I don't know
you were your father but I know that
that is a that's a very real moment
in somebody's life this is a moment this
is a moment that is very thick and that
will be a real hinge or can be a real
hinge in your life for a long time on a
lot of levels I'm sorry to hear that
brother homeward and pretty much
unexpected he was 58 years old you take
the best care himself but you know he
gotta expect him to die of a massive
heart attack Utley that age is you know
so I just don't know really where to go
from you you know I'm the oldest of my
family so the leader of the family so I
can't feel I feel like I can't really
[ __ ] off and then do whatever I want to
do therapeutic for me I feel like I got
a you know uh clues to where my family
is and kind of take care of them my dad
was the only person that supported me
saying I didn't want to have a normal
job and it does not the think now that
you've got it things like how the whole
world depends on me to take care of okay
thank you for sharing this stuff this
information here
you know I'm gathering you're saying
that your father you know he was one of
the few people who you know kind of
sided with you on you know you kind of
live in this free more freedom type of
lifestyle doing what you wanted to do
and that now that just because that
you're the oldest and that you have to
be the leader your feeling now is that a
pressure that you're feeling to be the
leader or is that a pressure that people
are putting on you to be the leader
because look just because you're the
oldest you would think you know that the
oldest is going to be the leader but if
people aren't asking you to then that's
a that's a role that you can assume if
you want to but that's gonna come with
you know you know the leader that's
short for leadership so that's going to
take a lot of effort and you know if it
sounds like you and your life right now
just look
and I don't know and I'm not telling you
anything but I'm just trying to gather
things here that I'm hearing you say
that you like to have a little bit more
of a freedom lifestyle that your dad
kind of supported that then yeah you
would probably I don't know what that
means to you but you'd probably have to
make some adjustments and some changes
but if people aren't beating down your
door to be the leader or to say you know
to take the reins or just because you're
the oldest then don't put that pressure
on yourself if it's not a pressure that
you know if it's just a pressure the
that you're putting on yourself only to
have a reaction to his passing you know
sometimes people you know something
tragic happens or something goes on and
we we will take anything almost as a
blanket or as a shield or you know we'll
create a you know a new shell and
sometimes you know I'll just I'd hate to
see you create you know a shell like oh
I need to be the leader now but it's too
much but I'm not going to do it you know
and then you end up in this spiral of
not taking care of yourself you know
fighting against this this this
definition this new definition of you
that no one even asked you to to define
yourself as you know I just hate to see
you get in a in a wild circle there but
this sounds like you are starting to
think about some stuff and I commend you
there because that's probably gonna be
uncomfortable you know it's gonna be
uncomfortable you know there's something
about when our parents are alive where
we feel like they that we still have
this Mulligan out in the world you know
and then we still have this ability to
error because they're still alive you
know and then when that cloud is gone
then suddenly you're the one that's
getting hit by the Sun the light is
shining on you you know when when that
cover of our parents is gone and so this
is a big moment where yeah you're
probably gonna have more light shine on
you and you're gonna be the one looking
at yourself you know it sounds like
these are the things that you
be asking yourself onward Yeti I advise
man I appreciate it but sounds like I'm
wood smoke and I am smoking a big fat
boring so you know sometimes you got to
do it anyway
why you hittin that heater boy you
hittin that six-feet Thunder huh Gang
Gang man but look you know if you're
probably just passed you don't have to
answer every question right away so
maybe hit that blunt and take a week off
and take it easy but there's gonna be a
lot of emotions going on and if you
check out all the time and you just get
high every time or you just do that you
might be escaping a great opportunity to
really feel some feelings you know it's
rare in life that things really create
huge feelings inside of us and bro that
can be a [ __ ] you want to get high
dude or you want to get you want to take
a ride brah let your feelings get you
son let your feelings Dawg you write it
you know blaze up a couple of grams of
your own feelings and feel that hitter
son get daddy had ha all right let's
take another call here here we go what's
up Phil what's up I woke up this morning
and my parents told me that um they were
going out with another couple to to see
an oldies band and um I'm in Atlanta and
uh they said the name of the band is the
swinging medallion so I just wanted
enough you had anything to say about
that I'm by ok Wow so bro obviously look
I mean obviously your parents are the
swing medallions you woke up your
parents said they're going out of town
they're gonna see a band
did your parents are swingers bro how
many clues do you need cat daddy cat
daddy cat Betty how many clues do you
need your parents are swingers dude
they're going to meet up with another
couple
the swinging medallions they probably
can't [ __ ] at the house with their
buddies they can't do that buddy [ __ ]
because you're at the house
dude you moved in you're ruining the
party boy get a job daddy are you
working at the library son
we'll check yourself out of there and go
get that job worked for a bigger company
go work for you know Chevrolet Enron
Nabisco get out there so your parents
can do that straight-up play a twister
they can bring a couple of spare DX over
to the house and play twister dude okay
man your parents trying to live a little
and you over there in the morning
sharing them sharing off the same jug of
milk as them come on man get out there
and get that hitter of your own life
here we go hello's Sto
my name is javelin I wondered if whoa
javelin okay dude that's a weapon
that's your name that's a weapon brother
but thank you for calling you from
another country man and I appreciate
that and um
onward hello there Co my name's jet Lou
always wanted to just call you a big fan
of the show and I'm also willing to
throw out a topic out there throw out
that's hilarious and your name is
javelin dude that's like because you
look man no offense it's not but you
that's like somebody saying a um my name
is baseball bat you know my name is uh
um nunchuck like Chuck like no nunchuck
bro that is a weapon though you got that
crazy name I bet you can you know a lot
of ladies like that they they like that
fierce man onward javelin also going to
throw out a topic out there you just got
all just curious if you have ever put
any thought towards reincarnation do you
think there's a possibility for it would
you like that found out that that were
true yeah just various things in that
areas it's sort of what your thoughts on
on the concept of there being
reincarnation yep I appreciate you
asking about reincarnation or Rhian car
as a lot of
people call it for short and I'll say
this reincarnation makes a lot of sense
to me and here's why because the only
thing I know for a fact is that I exist
here I know that I know I exist here if
you don't get into all the theories
about you know simulation and all of
that you know whatever it is called
freak
whatever its singularity if you don't
get in all of that stuff the only thing
I know for sure is that I exist here
that I showed up on a ball of dirt and
water in the middle of a vast expanse of
darkness and that I exist here so that's
that's proof I am I am living proof of
that
so reincarnation to me makes a lot of
sense because all you're saying is that
that would happen again that when I die
and you know and zone out from here and
disappear that I would come back here or
a someplace similar I guess that seems
very possible because it's already
happened to me one time this time right
now so reincarnation yeah so you're
telling me what just happened to me
could happen to me again that is very
believable because it just happened to
me that's like saying hey if I burn my
hand on the stove is somebody saying hey
you know what when you die you could
burn your hand on the stove again I'd be
like you know what that sounds feasible
so reincarnation Man Gang Gang I feel
that all day all right let's get him
this we sought to assign a best or worst
weekend for last month and we do have
our winner every month you can hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and tell us about
your best weekend or your worst weekend
try to keep it to 90 seconds or less if
you go over 90 seconds you're gonna
disqualify yourself and this is our
winner for May let's hear it one more
time here we go hey what's up Co I'm a
college student I'm studying biology and
I've been supporting myself by working a
third shift at a gas station
kind of in the ghetto of the city with
colleges and junior and it's usually
alright but uh last night uh six guys
came in and they should bought a gas can
and put like to be our owns a gasoline
and they seemed really calm your
children guys when they left but uh oh
yeah dude six guys
waaaaaah one gallon of gas a pro oh that
sounds like a gay campout about to go
down you know what I'm saying that sound
like a real barn burner and barn is this
dude that we met a couple towns over and
he's down though onward they came back
like two hours later just high as [ __ ]
probably on meth free probably on gas
bro
six dudes one gallon that ain't much if
you playing Huff's okay man
we can out there tired trying to return
the gas can cuz there's like twelve
bucks but uh the store policy is a
contra turd gas cans was just a gas and
all right that's a blanket policy baby
that's my policy - you borrow a cup from
me you put gas in it
nacio cup so they were like yelling at
me and talking all at once and they were
gonna stab me for it and cut my head off
and [ __ ] and that's scary when six dudes
all with gas on their breath are telling
you there's about two Isis you up over a
little bit of petrol can you know I was
a Marine out of high school so I'm not
afraid of any man but you know six make
me really concerned they end up yelling
for the gas can for a little bit more
they bought like $400 a random gas
station food [ __ ] like a lot of lottery
tickets [ __ ] up ended up leaving on
their own I look forward and 500 bucks
on them and left told me I was a [ __ ]
yeah there was my weekend man you know
what thank you for your service bro
thanks for your service station as well
because that you know it's crazy you've
been through the Marines and you still
got to go through the boot camp of
[ __ ] when six ignorant people show
up and I'll be a people that bask in
their own ignorant ignorant sometimes
it's too much but thanks for calling man
and guess what
you got that may hitter so we will have
our producer Chris will reach out to you
and take care of you and send you out
this past weekend prize pack would get
that Correctional Center blue t-shirt
that uh that tpw the only way you can
get it is by winning this monthly
contest so thank you so much and thank
you again for your service man and be
safe out there and when I come to your
city man I'm gonna make sure that uh
that I get you some tickets to the show
do you and one friend who don't drink
gas bro unless y'all ride on 91 octane
you know I won't hang out with anybody
if y'all sippin on 89 stays away from
daddy but y'all on that 981 idiot let's
go but thank you for calling man thank
you so much and we have we have a
submission for this month somebody hit
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three four June and here
is that uh that submission for this past
weekend for this month here we go hey
Theo what's up this is Josh from
Wisconsin I was calling about this past
weekend I had a really good weekend
started out on Friday I took the day off
smoked ribs for the first time which was
an interesting experiment kind of dried
him out a little bit but you know I was
kind of happy with that then Saturday I
got to let's go to the shooting range
with my brother and my wife and his
girlfriend and then after that got to go
fishing with both my brothers and two of
my nephews and my wife and then also
sing karaoke for the first time the main
song I wanted to sing my buddy already
saying so didn't want to do that and
bite his shed and then defaulted to
another one that I know really well and
they didn't have it so I was really
drunk and I ended up picking a song by
Mariah Carey called touch my body and
then I was just it did not go well at
all but it was a fun experience man
thank you for calling that's a great
submission for this past weekend you
went fishing you went to a shooting
range with your brother and your wife
and didn't and didn't kill either one of
them and these days that's a rarity and
that is to be applauded you know a lot
of times if you get tickets for a cruise
or a shooting range or something and
you're married or have a spouse or you
have a brother that you
in business together and the LLC wasn't
formed correctly and [ __ ] like that
you know what I'm saying you sometime
you're riding home with an empty
passenger seat but it's nice to know
that that's not occurring and then you
went out and got that karaoke you know
you get that Japanese music stylings and
you got out there and you guys did it
all and you did the Mariah Carey touch
my body and a man that are that goes
shooting with his wife and can then
finish off the evening sing and touch my
body I mean that sounds like a beautiful
weekend to me and you threw in the
nieces and nephews that you had fun as
well so that's a great submission for
this month for June for this past
weekend so thank you very much we'll
keep that in at the end of the month
we'll pick a winner we have we also have
on the website Theo von comm slash tour
you can get tickets Theo von dot-com
slash store you can get merged a lot of
great new get that hitter shirts we got
yeah we got all the new hitters man we
got that thought while or shirt a lot of
stuffs out there so get out there and
get involved thank you guys so much I'll
be seeing you in Calgary this weekend as
well on the website on the podcast link
you can submit video questions so you
can go there as well and next week we'll
start incorporating those we've gotten a
few and we will incorporate those
starting next week I want to thank
everybody again that came out there in
Oklahoma man I had you know just good
people good people came out and made me
really feel a part of the environment
there and we had our first single mom we
had our first single moms night out and
man we treated her well and her name is
Julie and I'm gonna do a follow up with
her this week and we'll put that out but
man her and her friend came out and they
picked out their own table and we did a
couple of nice things for them and uh
and so I want to thank you guys so much
and thank patreon so much for just that
support and making that happen and we
want to make that a reality we'll do it
again and probably another two weeks and
see if we can't just do another trial
run of getting that to become something
that's going to be a regular part
of being out on the road and so I want
to thank the people over at patreon for
helping make that that special night a
reality man it was cool and we'll put a
video up this weekend and some photos
and some actual video footage that we
got meeting Julie as well oh thank you
guys you know you know we just got to
stay ahead you know we might have a chip
on our shoulder but you know sometime
we've got to keep at a certain point man
that chip doesn't always serve us well
so we got to you know you got to put a
little bit of sauce on that chip you
know you got a fancy that thing up with
the new things you learn and the new
places we find ourselves cuz man that
old anger chip that thing doesn't serve
me anymore you know and sometimes I use
it sometimes I use it when I'm by myself
and I need to straighten my spine you
know or I need to get out of bed or I
need to stand up for myself sometimes I
got to go back to that to that you know
that Rottweiler boy that was inside of
me you know sometimes I got to go back
to that kid you know that felt alone or
felt unwanted or felt scared or felt on
you know disrespected or felt left
behind or felt less than or felt poor or
felt unappreciated or felt like he
wasn't part of something or felt unloved
or felt if whatever it was that you felt
or that I felt sometimes you go back you
can draw from that but that is but if
that's not our truth right now then we
got it we get you know you got to put
that on your back that ain't a front
pack that's a back pack now and you can
use it to power you where you can but
you know we got to get out there and um
and keep our mind open you know and keep
our mind open and keep thinking and keep
moving forward and we'll find good
things man that'll that'll keep you know
you'll find good things that'll pull you
further along you won't always have to
use that you know that raw energy that
raw
that gritty you know that gritty
gunpowder that that Center that's in
your system from you know from whatever
wrong do you won't always have to use
that to power yourself because there's a
lot of good people out there and you're
gonna see that look in their eyes and
you're gonna know okay this is safe
there's another safe a few feet or
another safe relationship for me to go
into or another safe friendship or
another and you're gonna keep going
you're gonna keep learning and that's
gonna become your fuel you know each
other
the good ones out there and I'm not
saying I'm a good one but but I'm not
saying I'm not so hello love you guys
but I be good to yourself you probably
deserve it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh and happy gay pride man I know it's
Gay Pride week it has been if I don't
know how many of what percent we don't
know [ __ ] who's gay who might be gay one
day you might be a gay grandparent you
don't know don't shun it now you know
I'm saying you might have a family and
then you might meet a man or a lady down
the road you know you might have late
onset homosexuality
you never know I'm saying I might fall
in love with a man when I'm 60 or 70
you never know baby I mean I'm just
saying you don't know what God has
planned for you boy you just don't know
oh okay you know what we almost winter
dispenser Jake will growl on the way out
and I'm gonna let us do that because I
didn't plan for that that just happened
gang
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate means
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die